hey we're here at Patang co on the old
Alameda Naval Base just outside Oakland
we're gonna go check out their pole cord
power generator which turns the energy
from your muscles into usable electric
energy
so this is the whole core generator
being produced by pétanque oh it is a
device that takes the energy in your
muscles and turns it into useful
electricity it's a product that we
developed to target the roughly 1.5
billion people around the world who
don't have any access to electricity
these are people that have never flipped
on the light switch they've never had
sort of the advantages of electricity
and we're trying to basically give them
that gift we actually looked at a lot of
the different possible technologies that
could pull energy out of a human body
and some of the things that exist right
now are things like hand cranks where
you're doing basically very very small
motions with your body and the problem
with that is that you don't get a lot of
energy out of it and it can fatigue your
body very rapidly so we were trying to
come up with something that gives you
really really large motions that allows
you to produce a lot of energy while at
the same time having a device that's
very very small and portable so we're
trying to basically target this product
people who've never had access to
electricity of any sort whatsoever
so that means Africa many parts of
Southeast Asia Latin America I mean all
the parts of the world that you would
think of as being in developing
countries so what do you see is the
applications in the developing world for
the pole car generator well for
developing countries the main
applications that we have identified are
lighting basically producing light for
around the home and charging cell phones
so right now you're producing actually a
large amount of power with this type of
pulling you're probably producing on the
order of about 20 watts or so 25 watts
of power at that rate for one minute of
pulling you get between 30 to 40 minutes
of talk time on a cell phone or about an
hour of indoor LED light so how much
would like a little kid doing this
generally well that's one to cool things
about the device is that it's actually
designed to adapt itself for either
adults or small children so even a small
child pulling on the device is going to
produce a significant amount of power
one of the things that we really wanted
to do with this product was give it a
lifetime in the field of at least five
to ten years in order to do that you
really have to make every part of it as
robust as possible
one of the things that we ended up
innovating it on was getting rid of any
types of gears from the system because
in a typical product if you have gears
in it that's going to severely limit
your life time so right now we are doing
pilot programs
in Africa right now so we actually have
been giving a large number of devices to
people in these countries getting their
feedback over long periods of time and
the response has been incredibly
favorable I mean people are just
overwhelmed by how much this device can
change their lives so there's just a
huge level of excitement both in Africa
and then we're also starting a similar
program in Southeast Asia really just
understanding the full breadth of the
market we just wrapped up here at the
tanco taking a look at their pull cord
power generator which they say could
provide energy to billions of people in
the developing world
they don't have wall outlets that we all
take for granted it's obviously a cool
idea with a lot of smart engineering
built in but the real question is how
and when these devices are going to
actually get into the field they need to
be cheap enough that people in the
developing world making a dollar or two
a day can actually afford them
you